Channel 8 is your local election
headquarters election day two weeks away
and just a reminder early voting is now
available it runs through November 4th
as election day approaches concerns over
worker burnout is on the radar for
County leaders thank you for joining us
at 4 I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Christian
Gossett as intimidation and harassment
are factors that have made many poll
workers step down from the roles during
previous elections but today Clark
County telling me they're ready
we've lost some workers but we've
replaced them and we're ready to go
we'll be fully staffed with less than 15
days away for this year's midterm
elections the Clark County Elections
department is beefing up staff and
training them for November 8th we get
last minute cancellations and so we have
to make sure that we've got spare people
that are ready to go ready to be
assigned we never turn people away that
speak Spanish or Filipino according to
Joe Gloria with the registrar voters
intimidation and harassment are taken
very serious in the past he says some
workers have left because they've been
frustrated with the harassment they get
at the polls this year the election
department has about 2500 workers for
election day which is lower due to the
smaller amount of polls that will be set
up there are challenges that are being
dealt with across the country we've been
fairly proactive in everything that we
do and a credit to the community here
those who have continued to work for us
in the past continue to come back I
can't say that I blame them you know
because you put your family at risk we
met Joseph Chapman outside the election
center and as he was trying to register
to vote he says Nevada should remember
voting is the only way to get change
maybe vote counts and this is these
votes count
well early voting averages about 32
sites per day and on Election Day there
will be 128 voting centers across the
county